the ipcc report is the most accurate
assessment we have
of the latest climate science so what
does it tell us well first up we've got
their modelling
on the impact of human activity over the
past 2 000
years and surface temperature remain
fairly consistent
until this shaded area here so let's
zoom in you can see how that curve
rapidly accelerated
after 1970. take human activity
out of it leaving natural events such as
volcanic activity and temperature
changes
fairly limited but add that human
activity back
on and that's where the warming happens
an increase of 1.1 degrees celsius since
1850 so what's happening well the main
culprit is more carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
and as that increases so has warming and
the report says that even if
we limit emissions to very low levels we
will still see temperature rise
because of what has already been
admitted before
and will reach 1.5 degrees celsius of
warming within the next 20 years but
crucially
in this scenario temperature will stay
around there or thereabouts and as this
ipcc map shows every half a degree makes
a difference with warming of two degrees
plus or more you can see that the rate
of actual
temperature accelerates so more arctic
melt
sea level rise and extreme weather
events everywhere
but the report does say that the worst
of those scenarios
is avoidable if we're going to reach
global net zero emissions
by 2050 so and this is the big question
how do we get there
take a developed economy like the uk we
would need to decarbonize electricity by
moving to renewable sources we'd have to
phase out
the use of petrol and diesel vehicles
reduce waste
and landfill emissions and move to lower
carbon farming practices now the cost
of doing all that achieving net zero
would be less than one percent of gdp
every year to 2050. that's less over 30
years than the covert pandemic has cost
in just two now all of this data
now heads to cop 26 where the balancing
act comes
expect dissent from people who argue if
we're going to have to cope with the
degree of climate change
anyway aren't we safer to spend money on
adaptation
instead